Ciao Mayners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo videooooooo
Ogni giorno migliaia di ragazze si preparano per uscire affrontando dubbi amletici come
metto l'eyeliner o no
lavo i capelli, o li lego
tacchi o scarpe basse
Ogni giorno migliaia
Di ragazze combattono con il loro armadio colpevole di contenere vestiti che faranno sempre e comunque schifo
L'unica cosa certa è che non avranno mai
niente da mettere
Come avrete già intuito questo video parlerà
delle ragazze quando si preparano per uscire prima però di partire con la prima tipologia volevo dirvi che mi sono finalmente iscritta a
21 Buttons
per chi non lo conoscesse è un social dedicato alla moda molto molto carino dove troverete tante ispirazioni per i vostri look
Tutti I nuovi trend ma
Soprattutto I miei outfit, con i relativi brand quindi potrete sapere dove li ho presi e potete direttamente acquistarli
dall'app. Questo è il mio profilo correte a seguirmi
La prima tipologia è la tipologia più comune è la tipologia che accomuna la maggior
Parte di noi. Signore e signori sto parlando della
Sclerata. sì,  perché non importa se la sclerata ha l'armadio pieno di vestiti se ne ha appena comprati di nuovi se deve uscire con
Le amiche se deve andare a un appuntamento galante lei andrà sempre e comunque nel panico più totale
questo l'ho messo duemila volte, questo mi sta stretto, questo mi sta largo
amore mio Ma cosa c'è? cosa c'è?? cosa c'è??
non ho niente da mettere, mi prendono tutti in giro mi vesto sempre uguale
Poi abbiamo la tipologia last minute. last minute è quella ragazza che ha scelto il suo outfit, è già truccata,
pettinata è già pronta per uscire ma proprio in quel momento lei guardandosi allo specchio si trova piena di difetti e decide
all'ultimo minuto di cambiare totalmente
outfit
oddio ma questa maglia mi fa le spalle grossissime, come ho fatto a non rendermene conto!
No, ma io mi devo andare a cambiare
La terza tipologia è una tipologia che vi assicuro esiste anche se non vi sembrerà vero, sto parlando
dell'organizzata
L'organizzata è quella ragazza che una settimana prima sa già cosa
Indosserà come si truccherà come si pettinerà quel determinato giorno, a che ora la passeranno a prendere quanto tempo ci impiegherà insomma, ansia
Sabato pomeriggio insomma l'outfit 1 per un cinema va
più che bene casual e informale per la sera invece indosserò l'outfit 2
con la giacchetta che andrò a ritirare alle 13.30 di mercoledì in tintoria, Marco mi passerà a prendere alle 21
se inizio a prepararmi alle 19.30 mi avanzeranno ancora 20/30 minuti per farmi qualche foto e postarla sui social
Poi abbiamo la Monotematica, un classico. Allora, la monotematica proverà tutto l'armadio, tutti I vestiti che ha e finirà per indossare sempre
il solito vestito visto e stra visto
Bello è bello, però... lo metto sempre
Vabbè dai una volta in più una volta in meno...
Passiamo ad una tipologia che mi auguro, non
abbiate tra le vostre amiche. Sto parlando di quella ragazza che
Vi dirà: "sto uscendo di casa" quando in realtà si deve ancora fare la doccia
truccarsi, passarsi la piastra, scegliere l'outfit, insomma sto parlando della Ritardataria
sì amo cinque minuti ed esco
Sì amo sto uscendo, tranquilla
si si si arrivo, sì
Amo lo so hai ragione scusa non c'è parcheggio sto girando da due ore giuro. Adesso la metto sulle strisce non so più dove metterla
Ed ecco a voi una tipologia che accomuna tutte le ragazze che hanno delle sorelle, me compresa
Le nostre sorelle non ce lo perdoneranno mai. Se lo ricorderanno per sempre soprattutto se le abbiamo rovinato
o perso dei vestiti. Sto parlando delle saccheggiatrici di armadi
"Mamma io esco"
A questa tipologia di ragazza poco importa se non sa cosa mettere, se la stanno aspettando, se probabilmente neanche uscirà di casa
L'unica cosa che le importa è salire sul suo palco immaginario e cominciare lo show
questa tipologia l'ho chiamata mai na gioia perché non
ho trovato espressione migliore per esprimere quel senso di vuoto e di sconforto
Che ti prende quando per una volta che sai cosa mettere
"Non vedo l'ora di mettere il vestito nuovo! Stasera lo sfoggio davanti a tutti!
mamma!
Dove hai messo vestito nuovo? "L'ho messo a lavare!" Ma non era da lavare!
La rassegnata è colei che apre l'armadio sapendo già quale sarà il suo destino
e anche stasera esco domani
Ultima tipologia, super super super comune è la consultatrice
sto parlando di colei che non riesce ad uscire di casa senza essersi prima
consultata con tutte le sue amiche sull'outfit e su tutti gli accessori annessi
Amo ma tu cosa ti metti? ma mi sono messa un jeans e un top. Eh anche io pensavo così... ma con le scarpe basse però spero
No, mi metto i tacchi
Come con i tacchi! ma no!!! Amo dimmi che almeno tu non metti i tacchi, ti prego! Certo, tacchi e vestito! Ma come tacchi e vestito?
Ma no dai ragazzi ma mettiamoci d'accordo, tacchi e vestito no!
Purtroppo siamo giunti alla fine di questo video spero tantissimo che vi sia piaciuto mi raccomando lasciatemi un like e fatemi sapere con un commento qui
sotto quale di queste tipologie insomma vi rappresenta di più
Inoltre, se non l'avete ancora fatto, ricordatevi di iscrivervi al canale e di cliccare sulla campanella vicino al tasto d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre aggiornati su tutti i miei video
Ricordatevi anche di seguirmi su tutti gli altri social: Facebook, Musical.ly e Instagram. Vi mando un bacione e ci vediamo al prossimo video